ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show Dan Soder Colorado your
representative Lauren brobert getting
frisky have you ever been have you ever
gotten a movie theater uh [__] or a
Broadway
theater [__] or a [__] I mean it's
gonna get uh the first time I ever
touched a woman's pubic hair was was
during Batman and Robin when it was in
theaters in Aurora Colorado in Aurora at
the Seven Hills movie theater Jesus with
the girl I was dating but this is how
stupid I was most of the time you go in
through the top of the pants of course
it was the summer I went up the leg like
a true wow 13 year old boy interesting I
had no idea what I was doing and then I
remember that was the first time I ever
touched someone else's pubic hair and I
was like whoa in the in the theater in
the theater through the leg completely
blew it probably could have gotten a lot
more had I entered properly was she like
what's happening yeah yeah she cheated
on me that summer with two other guys
who both like knew what they were doing
Jesus Christ that was one of those
things we were like I [__] up yeah I
[__] up but seeing Lauren bober do
that you're like oh that's a clear you
just got divorced move because you know
what's funny about watching like elected
officials is like George Santos is from
Long Island he just lies so you know
we're all liars so you know what kind of
what kind of lie he's going to come in
absolutely and I know Lauren bobert's
coming from the Western Front yeah the
other side of the mountains where it's a
Garfield County you know where you're
like sure there's Aspen yeah but then
there's also Glenwood Springs right
there's like it's not all Aspen and
Carbondale no it's a lot of like small
little towns where they're like they
shoot guns in order to show Joy they
show that they're happy yeah and she was
going in I mean she's giving him kind of
it looks like she's going in she's going
in my favorite part about all this my
favorite part about all this is when you
find out it's a first date right because
that's Third Day totally fine it's a
great point it's the first date you're
like she got into it yeah that means
because this is the show yeah so they
they clearly got drinks probably went to
dinner right and then headed down to the
Buell performing arts center right they
were probably you know in Lodo downtown
probably have a little and then they go
and she's just ripped she's hammered
she's ripping a vape yeah pregnant lady
asks her to stop she's like shut up
[__] right and then he's just fondling
those tits because he knows he's like if
I get her liquored up and we go to
Beetlejuice the musical there's no way
nothing gets this girl hotter right than
a Michael Keaton vehicle yes he's not
even into this anymore Beetlejuice the
musical it's just gonna get her in the
right frame of mind unfortunately Mr Mom
does Mr Mom the musical doesn't open for
five months does not work I can take her
to Beetlejuice yeah and my dick's coming
out there's gotta be yeah not the people
next to them but the people on the
opposite side of the aisle just being
like is that woman grabbing that dude's
dick what's funny is apart from it being
Lauren bobert there's definitely just
people in the theater going like who's
this yeah piece of [__] yeah and the
reveal the reveal that it's your
representative you know remember back
back in the when they when they did
commercials for movies where they would
do the audience reaction as they left
where they're like best time of the
summer yeah if they would have taken
those people and been like did you know
that was Lauren bobert they had been
like holy [__] like if they would have
grabbed that blast radius of who she was
around yeah it's just people being like
we had no idea there was a [__] house
operating at Beetlejuice the music I
don't know she must have walked from
Colfax it was it was incredible because
you know that no one knew until the news
that's right maybe even a couple people
at the theater maybe knew right but most
of those people around her are like who
is this [__] yeah in this dress just a
drunk person acting inappropriately in
public which is not rare now if I could
have informed them yeah
informing them that it was Lauren bobert
probably would have been about third on
the list yeah because what I first would
have done was gone now that woman's 36
right and they go okay and I'd go she's
a grandma and they go okay
and there you go that's Lauren bobert
holy [__] what's fun about her is that
you know she
is a wild woman like her husband and her
used to getting brawls the cops would
come which I mean dude you know honestly
the Colorado blood in me oh yeah
understands voting for that oh yeah you
want someone who's gonna defend your
stage yeah the way she defends her car
from her husband with a bat yeah yeah I
like someone where it's like oh you
really are like a Rihanna song and
what's funny yeah you know the whole
thing is what's funny about her is like
you know she had no interest in politics
she was working in a bar some bar called
shooters or something that was her bar
it was her bar she owned the bar yeah
and she was like this is what I'm about
and then somehow she became a
congresswoman I honestly
I get it yeah because 13 year old me
yeah if I'm making up a woman to jerk
off to that's it I'm watching all these
action movies I'm like she's got a Laura
Lauren Croft right a Tomb Raider gun on
her leg Yeah she's just you know not
taking [__] she's gonna fight right by
your side right and then you find out
she's just fast and loose out of she's
[__] in the theater which by the way
I would have much rather my mom made me
go to Joseph in the tech Amazing
Technicolor Dreamcoat yeah in that
theater yeah when I was like
11 right if I would have been there I
would have been like I'm a I'm a theater
I'm a theater nerd oh yeah if you would
watch Lauren bobert jerk someone off
during [__] the Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice you would have been like
we're never not going to the theater I
love the Arts right
more funding for the Arts no I mean
that's that's amazing that she did that
get up to TMZ where she responds to it
because they did catch her yeah yeah and
what I like about her she's just kind of
like hey now the guy that she's [__]
on like a gay bar he owned a bar where
they had they had drag nights he's a
he's a Democrat yeah and I love that
she's like oh [__] she had such a but
it's also people that are surprised
about it she's like no no I'm a [__] I
don't care who I'll sleep with anyone it
doesn't matter it could have been Al
Qaeda I would have sucked them off in
the back right so here here we go this
is Lauren Bowman I know it's you know
been a rough week or has it been uh you
know it's um it's always hard whenever
um
there's gravity put on the voters I'm
here to provide Liberty and with burdens
off of people so hold on pause this
already she's already got
she's already got hot girl giving a book
report
she's in front of the class
because you know she wants to walk up
and go like [__] happens guy had a hog
with that shoulder showing and that
Colorado hat that she looks like she
bought at DIA she's not a bad looking
woman she's hot she's hot and she
probably walked across the street being
like ah you suck some you [__] some and
you lose some right but see now she's
gotta like run that back it's very
interesting the gravity she might as
well give him tent fingers she's like
the gravity of the situation this is
like when my parents would be like hey
there was a hundred dollars on the
mantle he's not there anymore I'd be
really high I'd be like well you know uh
the spatial relationship between objects
and honestly with inflation and
everything going on right now I think we
can understand you know big Banks do way
worse yeah right let's see this Lauren
bobert what has it been uh you know it's
um
it's hard whenever
whenever here to provide levity and lift
burdens off of people so anytime that
they're carrying mine it's something
that you kind of feel deep inside but
ultimately all future date nights have
been canceled and I learned to check
party affiliations uh before you go on a
date but all in all um you know
it was mostly a lovely time and you know
I've taken responsibility for my actions
I would love to know how the the musical
ended and I encourage people to go and
see it
and see it it was a great time back in
the district seeing voters and uh so how
are the vote was taken how are the vote
is taking it right now are they
understanding at this moment yeah
there's a lot of folks who are
who are standing and and they understand
that it was a part of my you understand
it was hot as [__]
there's a lot of people jerking off to
this right now all over the world
there's you know what's surprising is
our response to Sarah Palin yeah was an
immediate porn parody right starring
Lisa Ann it was almost immediate right
it's incredible yeah that there is
already not a porn parody called like
congresswoman in the theater it's it's
it I would say that it's if it's not
already there it's in the works yeah
they're filming absolutely in the world
yeah in the valley there's a studio
converted into a fake theater right yeah
it's just if you're if you're not doing
that it's wasted time what do you do
they give you this it's wasted time I
mean she is that's what's going to bring
the world together is more porn parodies
and politics I want the hunter Biden
crack [__] [__] tape parody I want the
Lauren bober yeah dick parody I want uh
Marjorie Taylor green and a CrossFit
yeah like muscle porn
she's like a crossfit mom yeah and this
is like a super Jack guy on steroids
well this is like Colorado being from
Colorado you know it's like a little
wild and the people that live there like
to feel it's a little wild so this kind
of fits into what people do that's
exactly what it is that's right it is it
is mini malls built on Stolen land
that's right and it's it's you're only
three generations removed right my grand
my mom and I were talking my mom was
like yeah your grandfather was born
1924 1925 in alt Colorado yeah and
immediately I was like oh so there's
definite blood on our hands right so
what did you guys do you came in and
killed all the Native Americans yeah you
just broke all the treaties right took
all the land right and then acted like
what are you talking about the Chili's
has been here forever right right no
that was that Chili's ancestors that's
Manifest Destiny yeah yeah that uh that
Applebees off Iliff yeah that was
created by God is there anything about
it you Miss Colorado yeah I I there is
what you're talking about with the
people there is this like um
joyful curiousness yeah that people in
Colorado have right where they're kind
of like oh and what do you do where is
New York which I I still enjoy New
York's mind your own [__] business
and look forward whereas Colorado's like
and what to you who are you but that
could also go real sideways where it's
like who the [__] are you well you were
on one of the most New York shows ever
billions is one of the most New York
shows ever right it's very and being
being by your studio we were talking
yeah I'm in downtown and you're in the
heart of Europe walking here I was like
guys guys please because Young finance
guys are okay just come up to you all
the time yeah they think I'm Mafi they
think I'm a fee for billions right they
have a hard time separating it's as a
wrestling fan yeah I get it you're into
it if I met Kane I would think he's Kane
right the burnt brother of The
Undertaker now you become friends with
any of those guys at all any of those
Finance type people not I mean uh
there's a couple people that have worked
in finance that have gotten out that
like I know but no guys that are like in
it that are like I'm friends when you
were filming that show did they ever
bring in a Stephen Cohen arrest oh they
did yeah they brought in um
there was an episode in season four
where we did like a boxing match yeah me
and uh Kelly o'coyne who plays dollar
bill we did like this charity boxing
event yeah and uh you're you know all
those people you know me I'm I'm I know
Colorado folks yeah like that but I
don't know a lot of Finance people and I
was talking to this guy in between sets
when they were like changing setups
just having a conversation with his
older guy and we were talking about
something completely benign and he
walked away and Brian koppelman or as
David Levine walks up to me he goes do
you know who that guy was I was like no
I have no idea he's like that's the guy
that shorted Enron oh and I was like oh
good job guys like that would just hang
out on the set well they would be like
they would make them cameos in ways of
like if you knew who it was you'd be
like oh if you're super into Finance you
would know who that is right but I I
didn't know who it was I was just I was
just trying to talk to Rich Eisen and
then right I got shot down trying to
make small talk with Jocko Willett right
the link willing Navy SEAL guy who's not
Rogan all the time dude I got swatted
trying to do small talk with him what
did you how do you start small talk with
him uh we're just standing there with
coffees and or we were just sitting
there out of coffee and he was just
standing there and what do you like what
do you hey hey buddy what do you think
about pushing yourself to the Limit yeah
you look like a [__]
just antagonize them immediately yeah I
started talking to him about like oh
were you were you in from or whatever
he's like San Diego and I was trying to
talk to him about American Comedy
Company oh interesting I was like oh I
work that wasn't the route
dude it was like uh I might as well have
talked to him about Joseph and the
yeah I go it's pretty crazy he goes it
was a lot worse a couple years ago and
then it just conversation went nowhere
yeah you're like American Comedy Co he's
like I killed three men there I was like
I split two men's heads open that's what
we used to call Panama yeah he's like it
was ruled self-defense but good he's
like you bombed on small talk good yeah
and he what was he doing at Billy was he
on the show yeah he was he trained uh
Kelly's character I had uh Stipe miocic
and Tim Ferriss and he had Deontay
Wilder and Jocko and they were training
you like if you know we did like a of
course a fake training scene right so
yeah so you know when we're on set
everyone's in the same place in the same
hole is the show over yeah yeah this
final four episodes are airing right now
and and and that's it that's it it's
done there's no billions movie no
dude is there a billions Miami there was
a rumor and I hope it's just a rumor I
don't know God I pray it's just a rumor
I tell you what you see this face yeah
just know I'm on heroin right if I pop
up on that show
if you see me on that show I'm shooting
in Booth you've lost it all I'm [__]
if you're in billions Miami and there's
a scene with you on a balcony being like
the thing about nfts you're on Harrow
it's me talking to McDaniel yeah and
being like the Dolphins are like an
investment that you gotta sure just know
that I got I got black tar pumping
through my veins yeah things are bad
there's just certain things you gotta
say no yeah it was yeah well the one
time I didn't and and you know your
former manager my current manager yeah
great uh it's great uh that's what he
says every phone call yeah I love him to
death and I love them early in my career
I did I I did Guy Code right on MTV too
he told me recently I should go on tours
lizzo just out of nowhere he's famous
out of nowhere tax oh he's like it's
gonna be the only one who can do this go
to on tour as lizzo I'm like do
blackface
on tour for like but these were his
ideas he called me once and he went
he went I did some parody of like
pretending to be Donald's Trump's son
you remember that you're gonna do a
Harvey Weinstein parody you're a harvey
it's hilarious I go but that would be
like making fun of rape victims I said
that would be bad he goes right don't do
that very bad don't do that at all very
bad he called he um
Guy Code ended yeah or it was ending and
they were like and the creator of Guy
Code called me and was like we're gonna
do guy Court
where you can where people can take the
rights where people could take their
friends who have broken Guy Code oh and
they can take them to court oh boy and
it's all it's all the cast members of
Guy Code are the lawyers Donnell
Rawlings was the judge uh Melanie
Iglesias was the bailiff so they had it
all in place
and Stern calls me and he's like what do
you think and I was like I don't want to
do this is ridiculous yeah it's crazy
it's not my personality at all and he's
like
I'm gonna ask for crazy money
I go all right
and he calls me back they're in for four
episodes I was like oh [__] oh [__] dude
and then I did it and it was yeah I did
not fit in sometimes you just have to
eat it yeah I just ate it you just ate
it I ate it and you're like hey maybe
there's some good will come out of it so
billions Miami just know because they
never let anything die nothing nothing
will be ever let die so people it will I
mean look at the many Saints in New York
abortion that was wild abortion if you
watched that movie without watching
Sopranos right I don't understand how
you could follow it I mean it's crazy
they wouldn't let it die it's just like
we won't let it go like the Breaking Bad
movie we didn't need it no no one needs
it I even forgot they made that until
you just said that crazy they made it
they made a Breaking Bad move now
there's good things that came out of
Breaking Bad like Better Call Saul
that's what that's the difference a
spin-off can be good but you very rarely
now I don't you know I love the guys
that created billions yes I think
they're [__] awesome I loved I love
the guys that billions are about yeah
I like the real people behind Stephen
when we did season one I love his art
collection I I I like it and I liked it
he buys a painting for 300 million and
then sells it for like 500 million a
couple years later are you trying to do
that are you doing a little bit I'm not
doing any of that but I'm doing like I
own a few things but I don't know what's
gonna happen you're my schizophrenic
mother just died and we're doing a show
with her works well my mother was
bedridden and schizophrenic for uh the
last 20 years of her life but she
painted a few things and what we're
gonna do is fix them up a little bit
give them some political you know like
put some stuff in there and then we're
gonna do we're gonna rent a gallery and
soul and try to sell it to Rich idiots I
[__] love this the thing when you
make a little money what you realize is
that rich people are actually scammed as
often as the poor I think get it up
look at that oh look at that if you did
an empty joke my schizophrenic mind the
the previous one if you do like an empty
Joe Biden head yes no we're going to do
it we might do a bloody Richard Nixon
face or something that's gonna sell you
could sell it's here's where it's gonna
sell it's gonna sell to a 24 year old
kid whose Dad ran yeah Black Rock right
[__] one of those things yeah yeah
and he's gonna buy that my one of my
favorite moments with you is we were
driving back from a gig this is [__]
like 10 years ago maybe less we're
driving back from a gig and we went by
the mental institution and we were on we
were going over the Queensborough Bridge
and you just go or the Triborough Bridge
and just go that's where my mother is
can you just casually pointed at a
mental hospital as we're driving by and
you go that's where my mom is and I was
like whoa all right that was [__] out
of nowhere that's where she was for a
little bit and then she got moved then
she was in Jamaica Queens that was where
she was at the end and I I said this to
you when I saw you in La uh a couple
months ago in July or in August I said
Tim's the only person I know where his
success
caught him up to his tastes yeah because
he used to go to fancy restaurants I
would go all the time to because you
would need I would need like a
pick-me-up because I was living a very
broke life from very long yeah and it
was like you know I was living with
comics and like in shitty Apartments
horrible Apartments were in the kitchen
yeah legendary in the New York comedy
scene like the apartment I lived in like
Giannis Nate and Laker did a podcast in
this apartment that I lived in with a
married couple Justin JF who were
married wait that's where they used to
do their own 45th between 8th and 9th
Avenue Chris Laker Giannis Ted Alexandra
maybe that was the threat I think Nate
also did it like Nate Laker and Giannis
did a podcast in this Paul they could be
better or something and it was in this
crazy in this little bit it was a fifth
floor five-story walk up
shower in the kitchen crazy Steam Heat
pipes in the room your foot would hit it
you'd be burned you'd wake yourself up
rats bed bugs roaches and then you you
caught but you would still go to fancy
dinner I would still go to like go to
like a fancy Steakhouse and sit there at
the bar yeah and like stare at everybody
like I'm alive yeah and now you can sell
them your mother's painting well that's
my plan my plan is to set because you
start realizing how
much rich people get ripped off because
they're they just have all this money
sitting around and they're they're just
they need to get rid of it by the way
that's every documentary every
documentary it's just a guy that has too
much money yeah and then a guy that's
kind of smart yeah comes in and just
takes their money yeah and then they
don't know for years like there's this
Echo about get this thing up this Vanity
Fair about this guy that pretended to be
a Rothschild and he just bought a
townhouse yes in SoHo and he and he hung
out with like Leo and all these
celebrities right DiCaprio all these
guys and all these like Finance nepo
babies and all these European royalty
they're all doing coke in his Soho
townhouse and then he was outed as just
being this kind of schlubby Orthodox Jew
from New Jersey I love it but here's the
deal that's what you're supposed to do
yes like that New York scene should only
last for a couple of years and it should
be intense yeah it should be coke with
Leo and Soho yeah and then you've got to
get out of there because he got the best
of that scene in New York yeah what are
you gonna do that gets boring after a
while you gotta do it and then get out
of it it's like the drug dealer movie
where you know the part of the movie
when the drug dealer needs to leave
that's right if you're like you walk
away right now that's right you did it
that whole scene in New York is
when we were going on the road together
right I had just broken up with a woman
yes that was in that scene right and Kim
knew the players yeah yeah the way I
know rosters of NFL teams well it's
always interesting to me these people
that Ru that ran the world because like
one of the girls yeah that we would talk
about sure her father yeah was wealthy
Beyond Comprehension I mean it was in
more than 300 million so it's always
interested me like the people that run
the world especially people we don't
know who they are right yeah and they
don't want you to know they've no they
don't want any Fame the Lauren boberts
they want it they want they want it yeah
that's why you can be sure she's not
controlling anything yeah if you look at
the American government and you go oh
and you see it as like a crime syndicate
or a mob family all of a sudden
everything makes sense yeah when you see
it as like that if a bill becomes a law
that cartoon
then you're like perpetually confused
you're like I don't understand how did
they get this and that and then you're
like oh no no there's a whole element
that you're not even aware of you don't
even see social studies would be more
effective in school if you taught the
mafia structure more than oh yeah the
three branches of government right if
you're like this is the dawn this is the
Capo this is this is your soldier good
earners this is how they get made but I
always knew like I always read about New
York rich kids because I grew growing up
in Long Island as like a a Long Island
Animal yeah you were kind of like
interested in what went on in the city
yeah and all the city kids went to prep
schools and they all went to rehab by
the time they were 13 and you all went
to rehab they're all in private schools
like my parents tried to get me into
Regis which was like a free private
school I couldn't get in but I was
always interested like these kids that
live that life what happens to them and
the only way to break into that truly is
to do what this guy did which is lie
yeah more power to them yeah because
those people want to be lied to their
life is lies their parents lie to them
they lie to each other everybody lies in
that scenario yeah because everybody's
trying to save face and protect their
own interests so lying is perfect and
you do it until you're found out and
then when you're found out you just meld
back into society who cares and you had
your fun and you know who's going for it
you know who's not mad they got lied to
yes those rich kids they don't care they
don't really care they don't care it's
actually a little fun yeah because they
go oh my God there's a story about this
guy he was just so Random it's just so
Random it was like so Random honestly we
were about that's why we were in
Anguilla and I got attacked oh dude I
didn't even know random I remember I
didn't know what Anguilla was when I
started dating can you say that the the
can you tell the pr story oh it's my
favorite story it's my favorite story
because Dan used to take me on the road
early early when he was dating this
person and we would talk about like how
how out of my depth I was yeah I met her
on Raya I was way out of my depth yeah
way out of my depth I was living under a
train in Queens right she refused to
come out there
once
he was like
um right I'm not this is crazy you think
I'm gonna go to Queen which I remember
when you told me that in the car I was
like I agree with her yeah I was taking
a risk because this was the guy who was
opening for us like but I agree with her
and let me tell you why it's so weird
let me tell you why we would go on the
road and I would like say it to Tim
expecting him to be like that's [__]
up yeah instead Tim was like this lady
rules and he also knew I just love the
idea that he goes so I live in Queens
and he goes oh I won't be doing that
yeah she goes I live in SoHo you'll be
coming here so
she went to a uh it was Friday night
I had spots
yeah do a couple shows in the city she
was going to a um
a benefit as they all do right they all
get dressed up and go benefit things
that aren't real to society right no
it's fake I truly believe this was to
save art work
art in Venice it was something like
this like to the point where I'm talking
[__] I went California like he's a joke
and they're like Italy right
[Music]
um
so I go do my spots I know that she's
going with a friend this this very
wealthy friend they're both wealthy but
like wealthier the top dog yeah where
they're going to this benefit
she calls me later and she's like come
over we we we're we're done I I got home
early come over you know and I was we
were fresh into dating so I was like
yeah of course I will and I came over
and her friend was changing and uh I
went did you save all the artwork in
Venice or whatever I was kind of being
yeah let's talk a little [__] and uh she
goes it was a wonderful benefit and they
started talking and her friend's like
changing like taking off her earrings or
whatever and she goes it was at the
Pierre and then she looks at me and she
goes it's a hotel
I loved it I love that like I was a
small [__] boy because here's the
thing here's why you gotta have a little
empathy for these people it was great by
the way lives their lives actually are
kind of horrible yeah they're very cold
they have no Stakes they don't really
feel yeah they're it the lives you think
they have are actually it's weird
they're all in little prisons yes
it's hard to it's obviously not like woe
is me let's feel bad for them but like
in the full picture of their life when
they do stuff like that it's kind of
funny because you got to realize like I
always give the example there's just
bathing uh the speech Club in
Southampton the Southampton bathing Corp
they have this tiny little waspy Club
they don't let anybody in they sit on
they got this little stretch of beach in
Southampton they used to run the world
now the Arabs and the you know Muslims
the Chinese to choose they all run it
but the Wasps just sit there they got
their spots they got Granite check out
with her but they're sitting on this
little sliver of Beach and there's just
these you know Ichabod Crane type dudes
yes and the women with white uh you know
white linens on the beach with the
little hatch reading books and you
realize you're like this little thing
this is all they have all she has in
addition to the billions all she has is
to go like it's a hotel like yeah and
how bored is she of that hotel well and
how much does she hate everything the
one thing I realized by being around
those people I had never been around
those people from The Burbs of Denver
but they have to exist and they have to
be sociopaths and it must be cold and
they cannot feel or we will lose and
that is true that is literally true that
is that is true because the Chinese will
win if they are not called if they start
acting like us getting on stage being
like love me I'm a girl you know if they
start doing that it's over they have to
be they're gonna lose their wealth
they're going to lose their power and
then we're [__] and then we're all
done because I'm in a Waffle House in
Aurora they gotta figure it out they're
building a box yeah Village Inn is just
worried about you know that's right
going and getting diner food you're not
yeah but one thing I realized being
around those people is they just can't
[__] kids and raise my taxes go on yeah
all everything they have is great yeah
so nothing's good that's correct so
nothing is ever impressive nothing's
ever impressive and nothing you know can
ever be for example we had lots of talks
about like what someone's mind what
state someone's about like
they have to their emotions have to be
constantly put in check yeah by the
reality in which they exist they are
definitions of they are economic
soldiers that's right they're like you
[__] shut the [__] up that's right
Soldier up that's right you're we're
gonna destroy that person and you need
them here's the thing yeah you cannot
have a country where those people are
always going to be at the top yeah those
10 whether it's communism capitalism or
they're always going to be at the top
you just have to make it so that they
can't destroy the entire world yes but
you they need to be out there earning
taking risks being crazy jumping out of
Windows occasionally sending their wife
to the institution oh there's people
that are there's people that are sent to
third world countries when they know too
much about them that's right they're
excommunicated they gotta go there's
children who are cut off that's right
that end up doing drugs there's all of
that because you're right they are so
locked into like we need to make sure
this is okay it's the food chain who are
we letting in it's the food chain and
they always fascinated me they never
want they don't want people to know
about them and they don't want people to
join them yeah and listen in a perfect
world you'd go no Society wouldn't be
structured around those people and yet
no Society ever hasn't been yeah every
society in history those group of people
will rise to the top it's an
inevitability they're American Blue
Bloods it's an inevitability they are
American royalty on sale right now
what's funny and that's why I call the
tour that because you know really you
would think American royalty would be a
guy that looked like me in a shirt from
DXL
uh the same one that picture wears
because they make three sweatshirts
they've just given bigger people the
choice of three you go you go these are
your customers it's blue it's green
yeah
we got we maybe have slacks coming in
yeah maybe but it's like these people
the more and more I read about them it's
not that I feel bad like crying it's
that you know you you know my friend and
his wife they're teachers and they live
in Long Island and they have this house
they love and it's a it's a cute little
house they've got these two cute little
kids and they've got a yard and they're
so happy like they're they're they they
came to see me uh you know at the
Paramount they were like they're just
such happy people and they're so happy
for me and it's genuine like yeah
they're like you get to do something
that that you like and like isn't that
awesome and like they're just super cool
people and it's like they are much
happier than these people will ever be
well without a question when I was upset
about everything and I like wrote jokes
about it because I was emotional in the
moment I realized I was too weak for
that world yes I was way too weak as
well as am I yeah like I we are our
weakness is our strength because the
sensitivity we have to have to do the
[__] we do absolutely or look at stuff
yeah no no that world is we are [__]
yeah you know what it is we are the
rappers that act like we talk about it
yeah then you go see the real drug
dealers and the murderers I'm not about
that life you're not about it I'm not
about it and once once I realized I
don't wish anyone ill will I really I
reached out to that after we broke up or
whatever I wrote a joke and uh and then
I reached out to her and I was like hey
sorry about that I got all like
emotional about that right what did she
say she was like yeah it's just like you
know all right yeah okay yeah the thing
about those people is they know if they
let it seep in even a little they can't
even a little they cannot you know you
know Marble's very porous yeah I've
learned this the hard way
when a little bit of water seeps in was
a real problem real problem so if they
let any human emotion seep in it'll
never end dude there is a time dude you
know it's great I've read things where
every couple of years they fire the
nanny for no reason yeah so the kid
cries and gets used to a new one
you got to toughen them up young yeah
they're really it's wild dude it's wild
that is like Conan the Barbarian they're
like put them on the wheel of Sorrow he
didn't know
where I was going to school half the
time when I was a kid like they're like
we don't know I like first day school
I'm like which school do I go to my
dad's like I don't know one of the two
in the town like they didn't know like
they these people everything is is in
intricately planned yeah everything
they're not gonna date a comedian at one
point we were dating she goes so what
are you just gonna do comedy the rest of
your life right and you're like if I'm
lucky right he was like I don't know
yeah about that why don't you go get
more money somehow but that's what they
want but a woman like that you realize
what she has to deal with one day
she's gonna be in the Hampton she's
gonna be sitting there at night and
she's gonna have taken a Valium perhaps
I don't know whatever new things out
it'll be new she has a half a glass of
chardonnay so you know she'll be cooking
as they say she'll be kind of you know
the waves will be getting hazy and the
dune grass will be blowing
and then her husband's gonna come in and
go honey listen just so you know we did
9 11 again yeah and she's just gonna
have to look straight ahead she's gonna
have to he has to go we need a little
more money so we kind of did like a 911
type thing and and he's gonna go you
know and he goes I just want to tell you
because I love you and she's going to
have to go okay
was it for the best yeah and he's gonna
go yeah and she goes okay can we go to
Rome yeah I think that's great you
should call your sister she's coming out
next next week I want to summer in the
Riviera next year because they're gonna
she's gonna look forward she's not gonna
hear whatever he says now maybe it said
he did 911 maybe it said he cheated on
her maybe it's that he's never loved her
maybe it's that uh the doctor said that
she's not gonna be able to have the
third baby my [__] has a yeah my horse
pregnant yeah maybe it's a New York Post
is writing an article about all the
dirty things he's been doing in the sex
club whatever it is I got caught at the
Orgy Club she can hear it but not feel
it you know in war movies where they
show flashbangs go off yeah and it shows
the guy talking to the like in Save A
Private Ryan yeah he's talking but they
can't hear anything that's where they
get on valium those people that's where
they get on white wines and values
because like our Boomer parents were
like made jokes about farting and bodily
functions and they would cry and yell
and scream and their emotions ran the
day and yeah they were hormonal and they
would be taking pills to get get their
hormones in check or whatever and it's
just these women are you know stoic cold
statue-esque yeah and I resp I respect
the hell out of a cold [__] I mean my
God my grandmother uh I just learned
finessed me out of like sixty thousand
dollars [__] yeah and I was like that is
some old school as Luis Gomez would say
real ass dude of the week
dude I'm talking about from the Great
Depression from Oklahoma yeah you know
like this woman
95 about to be 96 broken hip would not
let me so for 12 or 13 years I've been
giving her money I've been giving her
about 1500 a month yeah because she told
me all I have is Social Security she
lives in a very poor county in
California right she's like I need money
without you I wouldn't pay my bills
without you I wouldn't have food so I
gave her money and I was like I love you
and then I'd always be like why don't
you add me on the bank account why don't
you have me on I can so I can deposit
the money a little bit easier and she's
like don't worry about it I got it I got
it
would keep sending her money and then
she fell and broke her hip and she had
to go to a facility she's 95 and so
she's getting rehabbed and I had to get
her enrolled for Medi-Cal I had to like
start like looking into it and I was
like hey I need to get onto your bank
account and she was like I don't know
and then her neighbor was like you know
I knew her neighbor was on the bank
account and I was like hey
can you give me this information that I
need and he's like yeah I also just want
to tell you real quick about seven years
ago your grandmother was like well I
can't put Dan on the bank account
because if he finds out what's in my
bank account he'll stop sending me money
great and I was like oh that's [__] up
amazing and then I'm I'm getting all the
information and then her neighbor calls
me and he's like
all right I got the bank it gives me the
bank the numbers of the bank accounts
and he says in savings she has seven
thousand dollars I was like oh my God
yeah that's way more than I thought she
had right and he goes well
in checking she has 62 000 and I was
like
he's underwater on her mortgage but
she's got the money
but because
Medi-Cal they do like a five-year check
of finances audit yeah they do an audit
I can't take that money out yeah she got
you got me this guy yeah she got me so
now I'm paying you now I'm paying will
you confront her on the air
if we could get a hold of her I'll just
go in there with cameras just her with
her seven on your side
I'm danger Buster Mike Russ is it true
you had this and she's like hey dude she
would do small stuff that my fiance was
like dude she's she's mentally [__]
she would call me by my dead father's
name yeah yeah I'm not Gary and she's
like okay I was like this [__] she
really was it was like she's farting
she's good it was like Spartan training
she knows how to do it she was like let
go of your emotions you [__] yeah she
knows how to do it but uh it was wild
when I found that out I was like you
know what I'm kind of impressed with the
hustle yeah of course you have to
respect it do you ever speak to the
woman you used to date no no of course
not it's been I've been like 10 years
it's been so long she's got like a
family I think she's fine I'm sure I bet
she doesn't even remember she dated she
probably doesn't it was probably just a
blip on the radar it was like she'll
call you an actor so I did in an actor
comedy comedian doesn't even exist in
her world dude I remember specifically
going to the we're at the cellar yeah
right this is while we were I was at the
cellar while we were dating
and her friend the top dog that we all
know that that you look it's a hotel yes
her
uh they were out at dinner yeah and the
girl I was dating was like uh I was like
hey I'll do my set at the cellar you
live close by I'll come over and she was
like great uh we're at dinner she's like
what's going on the cellar I was like
well Chris Rock just walked in so I
probably got bumped and she was like oh
so and so is friends with Chris Roth of
course of course
we'll come by uh I'll meet you at home
or whatever I'll meet you at my place
fine they show up and she's like behind
she's behind Top Dog and she's like
I told her she just wants to come here
she wants to see Chris or whatever and
they walked in and immediately I became
like a butler right Chris Rock was like
go find them seats
all right I go find them seats
the Girl I'm dating stands out in the
hallway with me or whatever yeah the
other the other girls wanted to watch
Chris go up and I I go upstairs the girl
I'm dating's down the hall and I go
upstairs to the table and he goes you
need to date top dog or whatever and I
go oh but I'm dating your friend right
and he goes no no she's the one with the
money she's right yeah he's right your
friend the girl you were dating
certainly had respectable money but not
like her friend no there is a difference
and if you're gonna marry a reptile
do one with a lot of scales you know do
it with the biggest tail with the
biggest tail yeah it was I was so out of
my element I was so it's incredibly the
morning where you read like I read that
article I thought it was very
interesting and it's like really the
whole world of the New York scenes to
kids comes down to like
doing blow in a townhouse fake art
[__] and [__] travel and knowing
famous people and knowing famous people
are traveling around and like having a
fake uh fashion line or a fake uh
handbag company fake sunglass company
something something that's not real that
gives you the license to just go hey I'm
gonna suck on my trust fund yeah but I I
got this dream to make [__] you know
I'm gonna do slinkies I'm doing designer
sleep I'm doing designer slinkies that
are gonna help yeah they're platinum and
they go down these large markets on
their Instagram of them handing one to a
kid in the third world don't forget
these are actually sourced yeah in
places where we can do good yeah it's
not just about making money it's about
doing good but also that is America
absolutely that is America that is like
the reason we I've been saying this on
stage but it's true the reason we cheer
when jets fly over at NFL games right
it's because they're not bombing us
that's right because thank you yeah yeah
go Bengals right here like after that
right pass you by it's a good point and
it's also why we love the military the
military is doing dirt that we would
never want to know they're doing right
but it keeps us safe it's what we think
it does sometimes it's the time it does
sometimes it keeps us safe sometimes it
is you know you know what keeps us rich
yeah it keeps us rich and rich is safe
and what's funny is we're in the
entertainment business which oftentimes
inflates its own importance oh it's
disgusting like when you see how many
people that we know that in-depth
knowledge of the wga strike in the in
the SAG strike yeah and then I would go
to my friend's house who is completely
out of the business they wouldn't even
know they didn't even know who strike
was they had no idea they had zero idea
strike was happening and they're like oh
cool what's the problem I remember I was
talking to somebody in La after the uh
uh I don't know what it was but we're
sitting there it was after some award
show or somebody made some political
speech I was like you know a lot of
people are getting sick of that stuff to
go here's when some of that started when
Tina Fey did Sarah Palin on SNL they
were very likable it made well they also
felt like it made fun of her in a way
that like Hollywood destroyed her
chances of being a vice president I'm
like well she kind of also did that
herself yeah but they like in Tina Fey's
impression of her to the moment when
America started seeing her as a [__]
yeah and they have put like I mean Adam
McKay said things no respect Adam McKay
think he's great but like he said
something once I don't want to make
certain types of comedies anymore
because like he was like well you know
you have these empty guys in suits that
are on in Anchorman but they're also the
guys that started the Iraq War it's like
no it's like it it's not that I just
think that like what ends up happening
is listen it's important to to care
about the stuff you're doing but like
you can't give it meaning beyond what it
has the movie don't look up yeah
I did not enjoy it right I thought it
was it sucked its own dick for the
entire movie yes I remember uh Katie and
I were watching it with my mom and we
like turned it off yeah we're like this
kind of sucks right and it was just when
it came out it was around Christmas it
just came out and then Katie was like
that sucked right and I was like yeah
that was horrible and then we looked in
all like Schumer and all these people
are like this is so important you guys
need to watch this and it was all like
all these famous people that were like
in the mix being like this is brilliant
and you're like oh yeah you're
perpetuating it because you need it to
be important you need it to be you need
it to be important because if it's not
then it kind of shows that you're a
little disconnected yeah I think it's
like people just having each other's
back
it's people going like hey man
you come out and the whatever nonsense I
do six months or a year from now you
come out and tell people they need to
see see that that's important that's
exactly what it is when Amy Schumer does
uh Will Willy Wonka the Chocolate
Factory from a female perspective
yeah when she does Willa Wonka she wants
the McKay crew to be like you have to
see this this is so important God it
matters what if a woman ran a chocolate
yeah and the Oompa Loompas are all
regular height they're all and they're
not Orange right not even a little that
that's that's out and they're not even
white I'm I'm really excited though I
think after the strike I think you know
we've got some stuff we're working on
now that you know might have a real shot
I and and I know that our friends are
doing really cool stuff I think maybe
you know let's get back to funny yeah I
really think there's like and I think
that's coming back that's the prediction
I think people are starting to get sick
of like their messaging yeah they just
want funny and I think like just be like
funny people are that'll be okay I think
that's the what we're going yeah into is
just uh there's not a greater Groucho
Marx wasn't trying to show depth right
there's an elephant when you have all
these meetings in La they're like but
what is it really about right that was
they're like what is the but you know
what you know like what is it about it's
got to be about something and you go you
know here's the deal it's about that
it's [__] funny it's about a dog that
gets boners yeah when it's around
motorcycles right and it's just it's
gonna be fun it's just gonna be funny
that's what it's about it's like but
these people
you know
I had a meeting with the president of
CBS during the strike and I did it
because I don't care yeah and I and I
didn't I didn't sign any deals there was
no money exchange but I just like this
woman because I like people that have a
few I like little people have a little
coin you also like to get in the room I
like to get in the room you like to get
in the room with the people that I like
to get the room because you know what it
doesn't matter they're not they're not
buying what I'm selling no but it's fun
to just get in the room and they're like
and who is this and what makes what's
great about you is yeah you get in the
room you have the meeting yeah and then
you come on the show and you tell the
people no it's just a waste everyone's
it's to waste everyone's time and they
know it is yeah they
yeah because ninety percent of their job
is that it's just fake nonsense meetings
wasted time
so I was in a room with her and I like
her and she's a really good woman and I
will do a guest spot on that show ghost
which I've never heard of not the exact
one I'll do the black one too but it's
the other one I don't know what it is
but if they let me on it I'll do it and
I'm not that bad I'm a decent actor I'm
you're better you're much better no no
no you're not actor let's well we're
doing the LA thing we're starting again
you're on a whole show I'm good enough
to come in a little you let me in a
little now and I was sitting with this
woman and she's a nice woman and she's
going um you know she's going she goes
what we're really trying to do here at
CVS that's how they talk she goes she
goes hi so good to see you yeah because
we're all so excited you're so funny
we're all so excited it's the best
because we're all so excited she goes
and we want the strike to end they turn
around like this she's like we really
want this to end because you know NCIS
is his 22nd year we're going to do a lot
of reality she goes but I'll tell you
she's a sweet woman she goes she goes
I'll tell you this she goes I love
broadcast television I just love it a
lot of people you know they're saying
it's Dad and she goes but I just love it
I and she goes and I said I said but she
goes and we want to make things here
that are about something you know we
want you know like what's it really
about I always asked that question she
goes what's it about I mean she's the
president by the way this is what by the
way you know who else asks that question
my mother the president she goes she
goes I ask you can you imagine like
she's just walking around CBS pointing
at things going what is that what's up
NCIS what's that about Naval rape
what's that about what's that about you
Barrymore has a brain injury like it
um what's that about but she goes she
goes and I said I said but you need to
make things that are a joy to watch you
have to cut it out now I say that I'm
saying it right to the president I go
you have to cut it out yeah you have to
make things a joy to watch and she
smiled and she went you're right she
goes you're right and I go this is I'm
not going to be with me they're probably
not going to be with me
probably not going to be with me
statistically it's not gonna be with me
no but here's what I'm going to tell you
you have to make things that are a joy
to watch you can't just me you can't
drown everything in meaning so that
everybody's [__] like what is going
on well it's funny I'm making everything
so heady when they try even to make
something heady and they they want to do
that but when you give them something
that goes like this she goes she goes
we're really excited about a new reality
show called raid the cage no it's she
goes raid the cage you're stuck in a
cage it's like you're on Santa's she
goes I call it Santa's workshop on crack
you go in there and you try to grab as
many prizes as you can and if you can't
they just let you out she's like it's
like a combination of something I forgot
what you said she's like it's a
combination of like Jeopardy and
Supermarket Sweep because we're very
excited about that and then she's like
we also have La silly
and she had like a Spanish accent yeah
and she goes that's like a Mexican Wheel
of Fortune yeah I went thank you for
your time and I got the parking
validation
but I'm open to chat to uh working with
them
I am I am open to working with them yeah
I am open to it it's starting to get to
the point now where they're making
things that 30 Rock wrote jokes about
that's correct we're like 30 Rock was
like well I think MILF Island didn't
they actually do that they made that
show and it was the joke on 30 Rock I
mean it was absolutely crazy yeah you
see that and you're like it's [__]
nuts well they have a new naked dating
show on HBO make it attraction like
parents are flipping out because like I
guess people like just talking [__]
about each other's genitals and they're
so great and I think parents find that I
think parents are basically like hey
yeah
I watch The Naked attraction about let's
see this is The Hollywood Reporter uh
let's find the one attraction the new oh
of course it's a full frontal new dating
show and it's coming to Max it's all of
course Emoji based right it's a blurt
out yeah here we go
ES
in custard overseas after being quietly
added to the max streaming service the
streamer added six seasons of naked
attraction a game show which debuted in
2016. in each episode a single Chooser
critiques and eliminates six potential
dates standing on a stage by
scrutinizing their fully nude bodies
which are gradually revealed one part at
a time with faces revealed last U.S
viewers are just starting to stumble
upon this series which was released
without a trailer or media Fanfare and
let's just say the reactions were
Priceless one viewer wrote this is the
craziest I ever watched on TV 35 of all
fatal accidents occur uh between 6 p.m
and midnight people age 25 to 34 have
the highest amount of drivers involved
in car crashes people aged 15 to 24 at
the highest rate of emergency room
visits through the car accidents of all
age groups you can talk on this we don't
have the camera on him but you can say
something this is depressing it's not
great but here's what makes it less
depressing if you're ever injured you
can check out Morgan and Morgan do you
know what Morgan and Morgan is
um lawyers it's America's largest injury
Law Firm nice
they have over 100 offices Nationwide
and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
it's not Dan's soda by the way it's
right company you can't just you can
just hear right
they've recovered over 15 billion
dollars for over 300 000 clients what do
you think about that do they give it
into the clients or just kept it well
come on I mean they get a little cut but
they only they only get a cut if you win
that's a good point yeah yeah it's a
good point if they don't earn they don't
eat they gotta get a taste they gotta
get a taste submitting an injury claim
with Morgan Morgan is so easy it really
is
have you ever been injured in a car well
you I cut my thumb up and uh a Boy Scout
camp I didn't sue them though I should
have I should have gotten Morgan and
Morgan but in a car you fell asleep and
you wouldn't you oh crap you're right I
did crash into the federal officers yeah
I felt yeah but how did that get
adjudicated they just they just told me
like they gave me they tested my uh
breath and then I was falling so I just
get out of here go tell it away they
slob if you're ever injured you can
check out Morgan and Morgan Their Fear
is free unless they win for more
information go to for the people.com or
dial pound law pound 529 I'm sure glad
they didn't hire Morgan
you're very lucky they didn't
go to forthepeople.com timtim or pound
law that's pound
529. well the hell 529 well they will
they help me Sue my wife or is that only
did she hit you with a car I mean she
could if she does then they will what if
we set something up will they will yeah
we can all get uh wet with it everybody
can get their big one but you got to be
discreet about that sure yeah
I mean you know it's just one of those
things we're not gonna tell everybody
everybody who am I gonna tell everybody
scratches everybody else's back for the
people.com Tim dot poundlaw 529 from
your cell this is a paid advertisement
shows like this I think things like this
is this the have we hit the wall like
this is full frontal naked dating what
is next penetration on camera yeah
it's like the episode of Always Sunny
yeah where Dennis goes we show it yeah
we show penetration it's the next thing
it's it's leading there because it's
getting to a point now where to shock
people you have to go so far you have to
show a beheading I know I was talking to
this kid there was a kid in a I was in
Raleigh at good nights and there was a
kid in the crowd 23 years old I was
talking to him about 9 11. I was yeah I
was doing a bit about 9 11 and I said
like what does that mean to you and he
goes I grew up with Al Qaeda beheading
videos right this does nothing right it
doesn't make me feel anything right I'm
dead do it yeah and it really is there's
well my friend's son had a little group
of friends they were like in their
mid-teens in L.A they're all black-eyed
as they say in The Big Lebowski black
guy in Iowa they really are just they
don't care they just watched you know as
Eddie the great Eddie pepitone would say
they just watch you know he goes most
people just go to somebody's house now
they watch a car accident and leave you
know what I mean so funny they just hold
the phone so it's like it is getting to
that point where it's like scary do you
think it comes back around do you think
it gets to this point I I think what
could be coming is a I personally
believe going back to the 80s this is
what I believe the tolerance for
lethargy yeah for being a big fat slob
that has no money is going at like the
tolerance for being a mess a hot mess
yeah is going to go away yeah I think
people are going to want people with who
have their lives together who are in
better shape who are you know maybe not
celebrating all of their imperfections
all the time not wearing them as a badge
of honor people that are so you think
shame will come back I think partially
yes because I think that like everything
else it is a little bit of a pendulum
and it's swung very far in One Direction
I don't think it's made anybody happier
no I think that's the problem I think
the freedom to be as licentious as you
want to be as crass as you want as
vulgar as you want uh you know I don't
think that's made people necessarily
happier no I think it's made them more
aware of the benefits actually of being
more you know traditional to be honest
and I think you're gonna see it's gonna
swing back to where you need order yeah
and what we've done is we've really
opened the Pandora's box of chaos up
well now chaos is like a mood right oh
my God it's a move it's a mood and you
could see it with the increase in mental
health problems the increase in
depression and anxiety the amount of
teenagers that are really going through
it the the social media addiction the uh
porn addiction the people that have
erectile dysfunction they're in their
early 20s they've been jerking off so
much you know it's wild I mean wild it's
wild to me that men in their 20s need a
Bluetooth well a lot of them have been
jerking off since they're 13 to like the
craziest type of porn you've ever seen
yeah desensitized for us it was like oh
[__] you would like gradually build up
and see something like Whoa this is a
full-on assault yeah I think it's
actually going to go back the other way
to where people are seeing the value now
in in religion and that can have
negative impacts too absolutely
but there is some value as an organizing
principle to people having some type of
faith-based
Outlook yeah and some type of moral code
wherever that comes from if you destroy
all of that and you decide that the
world is just who can dominate who yeah
you're gonna have a big problem and you
you a lot of the problems that we're
seeing right now come from that if you
make the world about if it's just people
eating other people yeah and there's no
code and there's no architecture for
Morality that people can live in
understandably you know you're going to
get a lot of unintended consequences
you're gonna get uh a crazy religious
fascist type of backlash that's one yeah
or you're going to get just the type of
you know schizophrenic uh you know
public space we have now where it's like
complete craziness where everyone's
darting around where it's like where
it's like Ukraine and this that you know
gender is completely invented this and
that it's like what do you think about
uh access to people do you think
there is a benefit in limiting your
ability to have access to someone
because you know when we started doing
stand-ups yeah which is not even it's
not longer than 20 years yeah it was
well if you want to see me you got to
come to a live show right you can't
check in on me on Instagram you can't
check on Twitter you can't do Snapchat
you can't do any of this is there a
benefit in having limited access to
entertainment it depends who you want
like sugar yeah if you have a limited
amount of sugar sure it can be fine it
can be very nice I think
people should scale back their
consumption of
I I think what's happening is our brains
are being programmed by algorithms yeah
they're being programmed by these tech
companies
it's very easy to say shut them off like
you know shut it off it's much tougher
when you're being raised with a phone
since you're 11. and now you're 25
um it's somewhat inescapable yeah the
drum beat but for me
I think that for example every issue
that I try to talk about on the show I
try to make it funny but I also try to
think about like what do I think about
this issue completely divorced from
anything I've read
about it or consume like so what's your
pure thought of it not what are you
influence when I hear something's going
on
I want to know
I want to have an intuition could be
wrong yeah but I want to have an
instinct I don't want to not have
Instinct you want to feel it in your gut
that's right I want to have an intuition
I and I want to base that on the life
that I've lived I I don't want to
necessarily always I don't want that to
go unchecked but I don't want to destroy
that what I see happening over and over
again people are destroying their innate
sense of what is true and not yes what
is right and wrong what is real and fake
and it can happen if you surrender that
impulse
and give it to a corporate media that
wants to program you or tech companies
that want to program you any different
way yeah because I have an instinct when
I when everyone in America when the
people that I've seen in Beverly Hills
spit on valets and go get my [__] car
when they all have Ukrainian Flags
outside of their house and they go we
care about the Ukraine I go I find this
in this is just curious to me yeah it's
just curious that the worst people in
the world became humanitarians overnight
why why were the people that pushed the
Iraq War really into pushing the Ukraine
war not to say that the Ukraine it's not
a tragedy people aren't dying I just
want to understand without the media
without the programming why did these
people the ones we're talking about
without emotion yeah why are they all of
a sudden invested in this one conflict
when we've got so many in the world when
Yemen there's thousands millions of
people have died and they care the
Palestinians the this to that they
really can and this we're only reporting
on this we're only talking about this
and I'm going okay as an American we've
never had a war with Russia Putin's
never invaded this country he was the
first leader after 9 11 that called us
I'm not saying Putin's a good guy I'm
not saying he's uh a poet I'm not saying
any of that I'm saying
sins for the last four years all we've
heard is Russia Russia Russia they're
fixing the elections they're coming to
kill you they're gonna get you it's the
Russians Trump's an asset of Russia they
just invaded the Ukraine because Putin's
a lunaty's crazy they need to start
reading about it and looking into it and
going oh it's very complicated it's not
really just like that but it it really
benefits people if you are able to just
if they can whip and you just go yeah
yeah you go Ukraine that's right give
them a trillion dollars and let's go
let's fight Russia through the Ukraine
forever there's a benefit right now in
modern culture of understanding how
stupid you are right and knowing
that you can't
get into something that's right there's
stuff that I'm like that's that's out of
my pay grade right I don't understand
that right I don't I sort of so I don't
have an opinion on it right because I
don't have any knowledge on it that's
right so how the [__] do I know so I
don't talk about you know one of the big
topics of Comedy I can't touch it's male
female relationships I don't really talk
about them you can't be like when you go
on a date with a girl yeah I don't I
don't that's not so that's a huge but
also but you do understand Humanity I
understand Humanity so it's basically
like your car can get to a certain uh
that's right it can get to a certain
speed maybe not up to speed with that
exactly I can talk about Harry and Megan
because they're con artists and I love
Connor exactly so then I go okay that's
relationship I can understand because
it's based on conniving uh con uh you
know that I get I'm in it I'm loving it
but other things like I I just step out
of it because I go that's not where my
experience is yeah and so I just you
know there is what's lost two things
that are lost in modern culture are the
art of going away yeah because now it's
like stay on it make money keep making
money push more stuff don't ever [__]
go away if you go away you're done but
that's not it's not actually what it
always used to be people like you if you
go by if you go away and come back yeah
you get to you get the he's back right
you get to return well Burnham does that
brilliantly brilliantly brilliantly
brilliantly and in a way that you're
like oh he understands what he's doing
right as opposed to someone that
overstays their welcome right and then
people aren't understanding why they
there's there's a uh there's like us
they know they hate you but they don't
know why they hate you but they still
watch your stuff right they don't
realize that familiarity breeds contempt
so they're like I don't know why I
[__] hate this person it's like
because they're in your ear right all
the time yeah all the time yeah you can
have loyal fans we were kind of talking
about this about the unhealthy
relationship sometimes yeah people can
have to certain forms of entertainment
for sure I'm a wrestling fan that's like
one of the most toxic fandoms yeah out
there because they're like I want it to
go like this and it's like but you're
the fan you're supposed to just enjoy
but people don't understand the the idea
of going away and also the idea of
saying I don't know
I don't know right I I I I don't have an
opinion I think that like everything
else
right now
what is essentially a snapshot feels
like
you know
forever yeah like everybody's looking at
the Dynamics of the current landscape
going
this is everything and it's not because
like everything changes all the time
people's tastes change their habits
change what people consumed for hours
they might consume much less of they
might still love they might find a you
know a new way to enjoy something it's
just what happens I I realized in my own
life like sometimes I want to bend shows
and then sometimes I don't want to watch
shows at all sometimes you just want to
read I just want to watch something once
a week so it's really the way I consume
stuff is not the same also you have no
idea how things are going to shift yeah
you have no idea very few people can
guess how things are going to shift
that's right I worked for radio I worked
in radio for years I worked at a rock
station from 2002 or three until like
2009 and in 09 if you would have told me
I was being like radio's dead right No
One's Gonna Be Good In Radio
without any idea that podcasting was
going to become his the new radio right
it was going to become bigger than radio
probably has ever been right you don't
know that you know right and so here we
are doing stand-up which has stayed the
same but we keep talking about like you
know Katie and I were talking about um
sexual innuendos yeah when you watch
like 1950s late shows or you watch like
early Carson
when they were dirty it was very smart
because they had to be dirty without
being dirty right I wonder if we
returned to that I wonder if we returned
to a place where people are like yeah I
want to be offended but make it creative
I think people eventually will go back
to what is good yeah I have to believe
that I mean I hope [__] I I mean listen
I mean at the end of the day that's the
hope and the hope is that we you know
like what we make I do the show because
I I think it's good and I do it
predominantly by myself I think that I
do things that are funny and that I like
it I can leave and go this was good if
it wasn't good I wouldn't do it I have
enough money I do it because I think
it's good and I hope it is I think
you've just touched on the actual what
what the actual thing is going to be and
I think as we move forward especially
for younger kids that haven't seen it
the kids that were maybe born in 2005 or
whatever and they're growing up now
authenticity is going to be a very
important thing yeah because they've
been lied to by everybody right so when
they you're very authentic yeah that's
one thing about your show that you
cannot argue right you are you yeah like
I've known you for a long time this show
is you right this is like Tim if if you
showed me us talking right here on the
couch 10 years ago and I'm like yeah
that's Tim right right that's him that's
exactly who this conversation we had was
the conversation we had when we were
driving up to Vermont yeah it's like the
thing is people say to me like why are
you and Joe Rogan get together it's
really good I go because we would have
that conversation without uh and I think
you look at the people that are doing
very well the Shane Villas is and you
know there's there's super funny people
yeah that are very authentic that's who
he is yeah and that's that's what people
want yeah I think people are sick of
being uh marketed to yeah of being like
are you a guy do you like this [__] well
I'm gonna talk to you about this [__] I
suppose just being like hey I like this
I don't like this right you find people
who gravitate no there's nothing
grossier than being a brand or a product
and that I think the influencer thing
people are kind of looking at it going
like hey man do you know I understand
making money I understand doing ads I
got tons of ads on the show but my ads
are funny yeah if you go the 80 of the
ads I've read on the show have been
[__] funny genuinely funny because I
get bored there is yeah there is a slice
of entertainment right now that is
um I I just want to say taken over by
influencer brain where people are like I
can I can sell that that that falls into
mine in a way that's like not authentic
where they're like oh yeah I'll do that
whatever that's money when it goes
against stuff like the transactional
nature of some of that stuff that I want
and people are just marketing a
lifestyle yeah they go like look at me
I'm at a party yeah I'm in Venice at a
party there's people I've seen I've
never gone to parties I'm on a beach
there's people that go to the beach I've
seen people that do the I'm doing
stand-up right that shot of like yeah
look at me it's like well are you
telling jokes yeah or are you are you
just taking a video to show people that
a lot of people have shown up to watch
you talk so the marketing of Lifestyle
which I see on Instagram which a lot of
people do yeah they're going like hey
don't you want to be me don't isn't my
life so fun that immediately I go but
your life's not that I know I go You're
just showing us that you're showing
because I know you and I've seen you do
Coke and I've seen you say to me I can't
get anything going on yes but your life
isn't what it's you're showing dude
there's I'll go on the road I don't have
tick tock on my phone but I'll come I'll
come home and Katie will be like I found
she finds like crazy [__] yeah
that we watch together and laugh at and
there's this uh Irish woman I think
she's Irish or she's British and she's
like into the clubs and she makes drinks
and she's like this is what we're
drinking
games yeah yeah I know this woman yeah
yeah it's great she pours like a [__]
cup of vodka yeah and then we'll take it
down and like mix it and drink it but
she just shows that she just shows that
and Katie and I were watching that and I
was like I want to see the real I want
to see her hungover being like Oh I
[__] threw up for it oh [__] I'm glad
bro I'm [__] blood mate it's [__]
bad like I want to see show us the show
us everything yeah no they won't do that
I I I we were sitting in the honest once
in a in a a restaurant Casa Vega in La
we've seen the the Kardashians Kim Chloe
Scott and the mom and they're all
sitting there
and the cameras are on them and not one
person in this restaurant cared nobody
looked over everybody was just like
eating quesadillas and [__] you know
combo platter number two and nobody
cared and then they got up and just very
unceremoniously walked out of this
restaurant
and I I something hit me I was like how
much money do you need
how much money to wear at a billion
dollars you were still sitting in a
Mexican restaurant with cameras watching
you eat guacamole
what are you afraid of losing what and
that's your thing about like not going
away these [__] have been on TV
for 15 years what do you think will
happen if you take a season off and let
other people eat guacamole on camera
Bill Watterson who made Calvin and
Hobbes yeah made undeniably one of the
greatest comic strips of all time of 10
years and then went away yeah doesn't do
it anymore right just stop doing it he
didn't come back and do like Calvin and
Hobbs or back at school right and things
are a little bit different yeah yeah
Calvin's got a cell phone it's like stop
doing all that you just did it he just
did it left it but here's what I will
say if you're not doing anything good
like let's be honest the Kardashians
don't really do anything good well they
don't make anything so but here's what's
impressive how much of it there is yeah
it's either you know because if it's not
good if you can't isolate a good thing
just make a lot it'll go the Rain Must
Be Long that is [__] perfect the rain
must be long it's not a quality product
but there's a lot of pressure there's a
lot of products we are back ordered on
it we've got more we've got some in the
warehouse and we'll walk it out to your
car and tell me young Tim yeah oh oh 809
you're selling you know some pride
mortgages in Long Island yeah if someone
went I didn't have I don't have good
Coke yeah but I got a kilo of [__] Coke
yeah let's do the [__] Coke absolutely
because that's what it is absolutely it
comes down to that because sometimes at
the end of the day you have to look at
things and be very honest there's people
out there that can really do good stuff
some can do great stuff and some can do
a lot of stuff I mean if that ain't on a
[__] t-shirt at the boardwalk and
those Kardashians are doing a lot of
stuff it's all that's all they're doing
a lot of stuff because think about it
they hit your dopamine when on a random
Tuesday you find out you don't even know
it used to be aspirational TV where
you're like I want to live their life
now their lives are so complex it's
confusing you don't even know if you
want it anymore you're like so the the
guy the dad is the chick okay they all
have different mansions and her ex-baby
daddy texted the other one and yeah it's
no longer aspirational like you don't
even want that life anymore you're just
kind of amazed by you don't even know
what it is you're just perplexed but you
don't even get the relief of someone
like Pete right being able to go on a
show like this and being like that was
part of crazy that we couldn't even eat
bread in the house because they were mad
at us so we had to eat salads yeah you
don't even get those because he has an
NDA that'll get him [__] you know
fine to hell I'll get him here get them
we'll get him here I mean tell me right
now tell me right now we can get him
yeah tell me right now absolutely the
Pete Davidson episode of the Tim Dylan
show I'd love I would love by the way
I'd love if you would go I've never met
I met him once on the Staten Island
Ferry I'd love if he'd come on oh my God
but I'm telling you without that NDA
that's right yeah it's tough yeah that's
what I want him on because they probably
lock you up yeah that's a that's a
that's like uh lock me up I'll eat that
uh Armenians uh snatch
you gotta go undercover put me in what
if one of Kardashians started dating me
that's what needs to happen that's their
next that's the next move that's how we
know we're in the death rattle of
society that's how we know so we know
shit's gonna be about to get here you
know I've texted Caitlyn have her on the
show I want Caitlyn on the show bad I
mean that's that I want Caitlyn on the
show back I think that's very doable I
hope so yeah that's an episode I want
Caitlyn on the show what I really want
would be Caitlyn Jenner Donald Trump and
me were we all sing I'm proud to be an
American by Lee Greenwood I'm proud to
be an American we're at least I know I
know I'm free then it would be over then
I would say to the people I've done it
for seven years I love and respect you
this is all I wanted to do drop the
curtain if RFK has me perform at the
Kennedy Compound this summer I might
take a year off stand up because if I
can just do to the Kennedy Compound and
do really tasteless JFK jokes in front
of a group of rich people that are in
and out of being into it and pretty damn
offended and it's a bad day and I'm
sunburned and I'm sweating and I'm
bombing in front of the whole Kennedy
Compound if I can do that I think I can
say you know what I I did what I wanted
to do yeah I got where I wanted to go
you got up you got up that high I got up
that High dance sort of where can people
come see you live you're on the road
danceoda.com uh I got live dates coming
up this comes out tomorrow okay wait no
Saturday this comes out Saturday this
comes out Saturday so I will be in uh
Madison Comedy on State uh Rochester New
York comedy at the Carlson uh Boulder
Theater is sold out but then I will be
at the uh in December I'm gonna be at
the Buckhead Theater in Atlanta I'm
gonna be at uh the Paramount in
Philadelphia
Vogel we added a late show danceoder.com
for all my life dates but yeah I'm I'm
on the road neutral full is the number
one dermatologist recommended hair
growth supplement clinically shown
improve your hair growth physical
thickness and visible scalp coverage
you're a bald man I mean that's a really
blunt way to put it but yeah I mean I
could use some hair I mean have you ever
gone to neutralfold.com to take their
hair Wellness quiz identify causes if
you're sitting here in neutral give you
a personalized plan for better hair
Health through whole body Wellness I
mean are they actually going to help me
or is going to call me a fat ball Pig
well I mean I can't control what they do
but I'll tell you this neutrophil
supports healthy hair growth from within
by targeting root causes of thinning
such as stress hormones environment
nutrition lifestyle and Metabolism
through whole body health
if you want your hair to grow back
I'll try anything four percent of men
have shown Improvement in their hair
after six months taking neutral full all
right let's do it does that make sense
is it poles or is it where they take
their hair off my ass and put it on my
back you take the quiz you find out all
right nice no but it's it's something
it's a medicine I do want hair I would
like hair again
invisibly thick or healthier hair for
limited time neutral flows offering our
listeners ten dollars well if your first
month subscription and free shipping
when you go to neutral.com
find that way over four thousand
Healthcare professionals recommend
neutral for healthier hair neutral.com
men spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l Dot com slash men and
then to the promo code Tim do this
because there's a lot of bald people out
there and this will help you if you're
listening and your wife can leave you
don't don't take it for granted so you
know get do something she's going to
leave yeah what's if you don't get hair
clocks taken
neutralfold.com men promo code Tim do it
Rochester New York gonna be a great show
Carnegie Hall November 10th come on dang
cool calm the [__] that's cool that's
cool that is so awesome we're almost
sold out we got a few hundred tickets
left to Carnegie Hall that's awesome if
I'm not on the road I need this [__]
go to that watching you at Carnegie
you're on the road you're at laugh out
loud
I'm in a movie theater that was probably
playing it'll be fun and then we're
bringing Ray comp out for a podcast at
the end come on a Carnegie Hall right
come on he worked at the graveyard shift
to the potato print Warehouse I [__]
love Ray company to go from the from the
graveyard shift into potato bread
Warehouse to working at the morgue to
doing a podcast at Carnegie Hall is
hilarious I'm gonna tell you right now
you're the best dude love you thank you
for coming absolutely appreciate it go
get a dancer.com thank you goodbye